It was the first day I had a friend come to my house, so I didn't know what to do. I was
so excited that I bought enough cake for four people. It's hard to even do that. If that's the case, I'll
help you.
Nishimura-san, if you eat cake alone, you'll get fat.  Hey,
where, where, where
[Music] I
came to visit you. Even though
today was supposed to be canceled,
Yume and I are here too. We all came. We
both made so much noise. I'm sorry. Akane-chan, it's
okay. I'll check on you
soon.  Now that I'm going home, I wonder if everyone is
dreaming about my house. Akane-chan: It's the
first time I've had friends come to visit me, so I'm
really
happy.
Thank you
Akane-chan: Wait for me,
sweet dreams
[Music] Well, it's about time.
Music]
Nishimura This is a free ticket for fried rice from my ramen shop. When you
feel better, come and eat.
Hino-kun's house used to be a ramen shop. What's
strange is that this is a
dream after all. I want to
see it more and more, Nishimura.  I do
n't want you to go home. I'm
lonely. Please be with
me.